this is going to be one of the best
carnage stories that we've ever covered
on my YouTube channel but the first
thing we have to do here is talk about
Flash Thompson bear with me this is
going to become incredibly important by
the time we get to the end of this so
one of the things to know is that in the
current Carnage comic right now and if
you need to get caught up there'll be a
playlist at the end of it in effect
Carnage had gone through killed
different gods and things like that and
got rid of all the weaknesses but he was
kind of challenged on whether or not he
was actually a God and and so what he
had done is he had come back to earth
and started killing people in a certain
kind of pattern now some of you guys
called it and actually realized that the
names of the people that he was taking
out were all religious Apostles and
there's a reason for that it has
somewhat to do with the idea of godhood
but there's a bigger thing going on in
effect Flash Thompson anti-venom has
been hot on the trail trying to
understand the bigger picture here and
one of the things that he does as he's
looking over all this evidence is he
receives a note and this note is
basically kind of bloody design of the
grindle right the spiral from the king
in black and all that kind of stuff in
effect it's kind of a way of basically
saying that Carnage is looking to become
the new King in Black right by kind of
bringing this sort of evidence back in
so what Flash Thompson does is he takes
it to Liz Allen the CEO of alchemax now
she's kind of morally ambiguous if we're
being honest with ourselves but in this
instance she's really more of a person
that can actually go over the sample
itself analyze the blood and then give
him information because the idea is this
blood or at least if there is any
information there will contain a clue as
to the next Target of Carnage and so
when he gets back in contact with Liz
Allen she says two things the first is
that the blood stain is from at least 13
different people and she says we've
managed to identify most all of them and
so far all but two are victims of
Carnage's alleged murdering spree and so
when flash asks who are the two others
she says one is a man called John
Statler Baker and the other is you and
so they don't know if Flash Thompson is
a target which it wouldn't make any
sense lining up with the motive of
Cletus because Flash's name is not the
name of an apostle right like flash the
Apostle of Jesus it doesn't quite work
that way but the other possibility here
is that it implicates flash so now it's
as much of an investigation to clear his
name as it is tracking down Carnage now
having said all of that right let's get
into the cool stuff so what this does is
this picks up with Carnage himself now
one of the things to remember is that
when Carnage came back to Earth he took
on the physical appearance of Cletus
Cassidy but one of the things to
remember is the Carnage symbiot and
Cletus Cassidy himself have actually
been separated for quite some time and
so in this video the Carnage symbiot
which we'll just call it the symbiot
from this point going forward that it
actually comes back into contact with
Cletus but one of the things the symia
does as it's making its way through is
it's chasing down the sky and it's got
this amazing monologue by the way the
monologues over the course of this are
going to be phenomenal right he says
every silur killer believes they are God
maybe not the God but when you claim
someone's life when fear consumes them
when they know that everything that
stands between life and death is your
will you are their God and the reason
why is because we often attribute the
indiscriminate loss of life to some kind
of a God right a man's walking across
the street he gets hit by a car well it
must have been his time according to
God's plan if you believe in that sort
of thing and so people try to find logic
and reason or try to find some kind of
Greater understanding and in fact that's
one of the things that the symbiot is
going to hit on here in a little while
and so when people consider this idea
that like a being is coming for them and
he's going to destroy them that in that
moment because they control life and
death they are in effect
God and so this dude gets taken out now
the thing here is that continuing on
right the symbiot says scratch the
surface and you reveal the real world
all red and raw and senseless now one of
the things that you will notice here is
that it does kind of address itself in
the sense that technically speaking the
redhaired Cletus cidy that you see is
more just kind of like a physical form
created by the symbiot but it is in
effect the symbiot talking to itself and
answering it self right so we can just
kind of assume that's the case going
forward but literally it's just kind of
like what's bothering you right and the
syat says I that's to say the previous
me have been alive all along yet this is
the best that he could do and the S it
says we are better now we are more
powerful and it's like perhaps and it
says but he the other one he is a loose
thread and I would like to pull it and
the questions asked do you think he
would stand in our way to which the
response is given nothing can stand in
our way my love I am the end of the
world as we know it now this is where
things get cool because technically you
could argue the symbiot is going to
eradicate all life on Earth which would
seem way too simple the reality here is
far more interesting than that right the
symia kind of asks this question Muses
this question right what's the
difference between a madman and a
prophet right imagination branding AAR
of good robes I could kill everyone in
here right now and the question is asked
why don't we and the response the same
reason a benevolent God does not wipe
away all illness and pain I suppose and
so the question is but why didn't he and
the answer isn't really given right is I
can smell him he was here this chair
every time he'd come here he'd sit right
here here's another question what came
first the Carnage or the anger so is a
really really interesting kind of
Quagmire because it brings into sharp
relief the nature of like how we see
gods and how they function in the world
right why doesn't a benevolent God get
rid of all illness and all disease and
all that kind of stuff right is it a
place of testing right like why do
places like Hell exist right using the
Stephen Hawking quote what god making
hell for people who ask such questions
that's the kind of thing that's just
really sort of thrown in here and so
what you do is you pick up with
basically the symbiot heading in a
particular direction and this is where
things get cool right the question is
why are we driving right the answer why
do Pilgrims walk right is it this
spiritual journey and it's like well you
know it's it's something like that but
they end up coming across this guy who's
just sort of holding a sign and is
effectively a hitchhiker they end up
picking him up and there's no real
indication as to whether or not the
symbiot is going to kill this guy that's
one of the big differences between like
uh the Joker and the Carnage symbia The
Joker would kill you just for
inconveniencing him right like that's
literally reason enough sometimes
there's no reason at all because it just
makes for good sport but when it comes
to someone like Carnage it's usually to
serve a particular purpose even if it's
for no other purpose than to sew chaos
and to reap madness out there in the
world that is still a purpose and so
what you do is you pick up with a
conversation between these two guys and
this guy is basically a buffoon right he
says and it's all done by hand 37 years
he worked on this stone monument some
say he was crazy and the Sim is just
getting more and more annoyed with this
guy right the question is asked tell me
in your opinion what is the difference
between a madman and a prophet right
that's the that's the question the
symbiot asks right this guy response
great question my man I think like a
prophet speaks like Divine truth like
their soul is touched by the Divine the
guys kind of has no real idea what he's
talking about and he talks like an idiot
right you know but like if you speak
your truth truth right from the heart
then you're like a prophet for the
universe you know like it can never be
Madness it's it's just this guy is just
a total goof and so In This Moment like
things just get more and more irritating
until this guy says sometimes I think
like if I wrote a book like The Book of
Mark where i' tell my truth like my
experiences I would live forever and
that's when the symbiot realizes this
guy's name is Mark he fits perfectly in
line with the number of Apostles that
have been taken out the symbiot kills
this guy literally drives off a cliff
and tears this guy in half while they're
doing it in the midst of it all they end
up in New Market and the reason for this
is that as the Symbiotes kind of musing
to itself with just some victim in toe
that he just kind of sits up against a
bus bench which is kind of brutal right
kind of weird that he starts talking to
himself he kind of starts musing to
himself he says we came here on our
first saint Estus field trip the same
Estus orphanage where Cletus Cassidy was
originally raised and it says it would
well technically raised after he killed
his mom I think it was I don't remember
the the uh specifics of his origin story
throw it down in the comments he says it
would as it turned out also be our last
it was sponsored by some socialite who
wanted to do just enough to save herself
a space in heaven and then this
disembodied voice comes out of nowhere
could have gotten us central heating but
she wanted to parade her welfare around
the poor orphans the simit responds back
we stopped at this place for ice cream
Town's people smiled placidly all pity
and discomfort they spoke to us slowly
enunciating every simple word with
determination the shop had every flavor
in the world but they served us and then
this disembodied voice comes in again
charity with a Sprinkle of content the
symbiot speaks up as it makes its way
way down into the sewers there was a boy
Jonas or Jan or something pathetic
creature had this unhealthy obsession
with screws this voice comes back we
called him Phillips he never understood
why the halfwit the response of the
symbiot collected them old rusty screws
and nails kept them in a box under his
bed counted them every night the voice
comes back we stole some from time to
time removed one put it back Weeks Later
drove him up the walls the symbia Chimes
in again this is one of the coolest like
back and forth that I've ever seen a
Commish right this says I remember he
said as he gobbled up the singular scoop
of ice cream that we were given this
person responds that the sewers in New
Market were probably nicer than our
rooms at St Estus and this is when the
symbiot says in the years to come I
would find out that he was quite right I
have a question for you you old man this
guy Cletus Cassidy the one who can alter
reality in a localized space right this
guy says then ask the symbiot says
what's the difference between a madman
and a prophet what does Cletus say the
audience right it's one of the coolest
things the coolest back and forth here
because when that happens and this is
where things get a little bit murky when
that happens you basically have the two
of them engaging in a conversation now
here's what we don't know about Cletus
Cassidy as he exists now Cletus having
the ability to alter reality was less
due to his ability to control the
molecular structure of matter and more
due to the fact that he had taken on a
symbiot of its own and then literally
used the power of the symbiot to kind of
erect a house so anytime anybody walked
into that house he could change it he
could shape it he could make it anything
that he wanted it to be the question
here is is that what's going on here and
the answer seems to be no and you'll see
what we're talking about as time goes
goes on but it's just kind of like this
really really cruel back and forth right
because a symbiot asks and can you judge
a god By Their audience the response of
Cletus let's bloody well hope not for
the sake of the Gods and so then he asks
is that what this is about would you
like to be a God or would you like to be
a god Butcher and the question of the
symbiot would it not take one to do the
other and that's kind of the question
that we found ourselves asking right in
the previous Carnage run when you had
Ram V kind of writing everything it was
in a lot of ways like the Carnet symbia
traveling throughout the Multiverse
going into the death of the venomverse
and it was killing all these different
Venom symbiotes across the Multiverse it
was absorbing their power which in turn
eliminated that weakness right he could
for example kill one of the Venoms that
was immune to Fire and that in absorbing
that Venom's power now Cletus is immune
to Fire or the Symbiotes immune to fire
it was that kind of a thing but then
suddenly it just stopped at the very
beginning of this Venom run and in the
first issue it established that he was
trying to achieve legitimate godhood he
already had it in terms of power he was
trying to achieve it in terms of
perception because what you end up doing
here is you have this moment where
Cletus leads the symbiot right as
they're kind of talking back and forth
going back and forth a little bit of
banter that what ends up happening it's
cetus says now Carnage my sweet little
puppy don't be mean and what he does is
he basically opens a gas line fills the
entire room with natural gas and lights
a butane lighter which the whole room
immerses into flames right so we get
this really cool thing first come the
flames and that's when Carnage is like
that was your plan then comes the fury
right what do you think fire will do to
me I expected more from you Cletus and
that's where Cletus is like and I from
you what does it say about you God
butcher if you cannot even kill an old
man and that's when Carnage is like it
takes more than Flames to stop me Cletus
and literally devours Cletus cidy but in
that moment something goes wrong right
like he literally starts hacking and
coughing and all that kind of stuff and
ends up spitting up Cletus Cassity and
his entirety and what we end up finding
out is that Cletus had this genius idea
that what Cletus did is he basically
used concentrated antibodies he injected
himself with that it was the closest he
could get to anti an Venom because
basically Flash Thompson as antivenom
has the ability to neutralize other
symbiotes at least that seems to be the
case we don't know how his powers are
going to stack up to the new abilities
of Carnage and so Cletus literally says
I thought it would kill you but you were
as hard to kill as me tell me Carnage if
we are the gods who are the Devils now
regarding the bigger role of Carnage
right the bigger goal that he's trying
to achieve because it's one thing to
start going around and taking people out
who all have the names of the Apostles
but what's the bigger plan here what we
end up finding out at least from flash
Thompson's perspective is that there is
a video that surfaces online where a guy
is Tracked Down whose name is John and
he shot out now as we know Carnage
doesn't use guns right they're too quick
you can't Savor all the little emotions
you know but no quite literally like he
never uses guns and so Flash Thompson
figures out quickly this is a copycat
right because with Cletus going around
everyone named Mark he kills everyone
named John he kills right anyone who's
named after an apostle he kills and
because there are people out there who
were just obsessed with Carnage if for
no other reason than reasons that Mak
sense to nobody but themselves they
ultimately ended up copying his actions
but the bigger goal of Carnage here was
to build a religion because one of the
things he learned in his time traveling
the Multiverse is that when it comes
comes to Gods like Thor and Odin and
even like Gore the god butcher they're
only as powerful as the people or the
number of people who believe in them of
what use is a God that has no followers
that never prays to them right it's one
of the big things that was established
in Jason Aaron's run on Thor it was
continued in Donnie Kate's run and it's
something that's being maintained here
the power of gods derives from prayer
what better way to become a true God and
all the power that comes with it in
addition to the power he already has
than to actually incite a movement in
his name that people will start seeing
him as a God and start worshiping him as
a God and acting in a way that would
earn the favor of Carnage himself and so
switching back over to the symbiot
itself right kind of taunting Cletus a
little bit ask the question like does it
hurt and the response of Cletus
absolutely it does right of course
that's when the symbat says good your
antib bodies are but a temporary
inconvenience had it been antivenom it
would have been another matter at least
for now now that's one of the things to
know is because again this continues on
the exact same thing that's been
happening over the course of the entire
Carnage series because Cletus cidy has
basically injected himself with
concentrated antibodies if the symbiot
consumes him the Symbiotes will be
immune to antivenom you guys see how it
all comes together right like you see
how it all comes together that the
symbiot is basically becoming this
Unstoppable Force it's immune to fire
it's immune to Sonics is immune to all
the traditional weaknesses of a symbiot
the one thing it was not immune to was
the power of antivenom we found that out
during the story of the death of Venom
verse right antivenom was the one thing
that could stop Carnage so what better
way than to take a detour from his
entire conquering of the Multiverse and
an attempt to basically kill Eddie Brock
Venom and become the new king and black
of the universe and like take out Cletus
Cassidy or somebody and then find an
immunity to antivenom itself and so
that's exactly what he does he literally
slices off the top of the head of Cletus
cidy consumes his brain and in doing so
becomes immune to antivenom now here's
where things get wild right remember
what we said earlier that Flash Thompson
was basically told that one of the blood
samples belonged to a guy named John
Flash Thompson goes on a mission to find
this guy and to try to rescue this guy
and so what he does is he shows up in
this location right where Cletus Cassidy
right the symbiot who's now absorbed or
killed Cletus we can just start calling
him Carnage again right to kind of keep
things clear that Carnage is basically
making his way right he's essentially
out and he's the one that's actually
giving us this monologue here right he
says I was prepared to wait but he which
is to say Flash Thompson is right on
time flash does his best imitation of an
ordinary man the symbiot disguises him
well gives him a costume changes his
fingerprints shrinks his muscles into a
non-threatening frame right on time
right and that's where he says like this
is the place everything looks fine and
that's when Carnage says in a world of
disappointment Flash Thompson is not
disappointing because this is the
address of John and Carnage says his
symbiot ears will hear what no one else
does muffled and far away yet still
there he will smell the faint scent of
feces and blood and he will want to do
the right thing himself and oh how I
love a hero because when he comes across
this door right he just says live love
laugh Written in Blood which is exactly
what Carnage would have done back during
the early Maximum Carnage days but he
hears John literally tied up in the
basement screaming for help but when
flash gets there he flips on the light
switch it turns out it's a trap because
as soon as the light switch gets turned
on Jon's head gets blown to Pieces
basically flash killed this guy with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end I told you this
story is phenomenal it took three issues
to get to a point where it matters but
it's amazing if you guys need to get
caught up on Carnage make sure you click
this link to the playlist and I will
catch you all in the next video video
peace